yeah I think in a different life if
comedy didn't work out for you I feel
like you would have been an agent of
sorts or a foreign agent for adult I
would know I would have my own
production company I would have I would
be like a devil's film or I yeah yeah oh
really
yeah yeah I would be like legit you know
I mean number one I would take care of
my ladies yeah
I mean I'd be like a Papa kind of a
thing right papa productions know it hug
a lot of the you okay how are you
feeling I don't know hugging in a pervy
way my girl's a roller coaster nope it's
like you know I would go to like if I
was an agent like let's say I was your
agent Sasha right and after your first
scene you know I mean I would probably
put my arm around you wipe you down yeah
I go we'll take a shower first and then
wipe you down and I'll put my arm around
you just very like father-daughter type
and go how you feeling kiddo kiddo
you're like living out your own fantasy
yeah yeah yeah another thing I need to
would it about you know and I need your
expertise on this what is this family so
lately for the past couple years you
know how like the the couch auditions
okay now he strictly just does old Jay
so decrepit 80 year old old old old oj
oj Nicole Bronson some video
he likes yeah really really really like
geriatric looking men with 18 year olds
that combo that he's really into okay
and what are your thoughts on that and
do you think that he's just projecting
his feelings yourself yeah the no he's I
I want to know what the the the feeling
is or the drive behind that's really
weird I was actually thinking about not
to make this about me but I was thinking
about a scene like that I did recently
yeah I was reflecting on I was like oh
you did a scene with an old man he was
in geriatric but he was pretty [ __ ]
old oh she had been in his mid-60s
ah but like not healthy so he looked
much older yeah yeah yeah maybe even
late 60 and you that wasn't one of the
last scenes you did no no no when you
did that scene was it uncomfortable
working or now mm-hmm I mean no yes and
no it was awkward in my brain it was
awkward yeah but I could say that there
was like worse moments and worst
experiences when he came like as long as
somebody was hygienic I could hang up my
[ __ ] feelings Rai Rai Rai right I
think that would be my big thing too
because I my real like clean freak like
I breath is a really big thing for me
and I think as long as someone is fully
clean I could look past anything right
but you have a writer like you know
sometimes when I go on the road like I
have a rider like I need Red Bull in the
room right I need three balls of water
all these things can't you go can the
person be clean yeah I left I left like
there were scenes where I would leave oh
you would yeah Wow like this is not
acceptable conditions right yeah so um
what is the worst one that you had the
worst experience it's probably a girl
really and she was tilapia funny enough
my my worst experience yeah
big fish are these thinking it's my code
word that I know yeah he's with all my
friends Philippi palapa doesn't have
like the omega fatty acid you get from
other fish so it's not even a good price
like a man it's like the one they farm
in those vats and they swim and eat
their own [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
tilapia because in my game start do
Valley right tilapia tilapia is the
easiest fish to catch which means they
bottom bottom dweller
hello sleepers we're gonna take a quick
break to share some amazing sponsors
with you